[Music]
I welcome back to the third edition of
quantified I am your host international
arbiter not master my cover
and I'm here with national master NIC
Carlo who's celebrating his four year
anniversary of becoming a national
master so that's pretty cool so was that
your biggest chess accomplishment so far
yeah yeah for sure
I won that for a long time and you got
it so congratulations on that and do you
have any more aspirations in a chess um
you know it's something I may be
neglected growing up I'm just trying to
have as much fun as I can all right so
you're in it for the fun okay and you
had an impressive first round victory
over a chess expert Jason's out can you
tell me a little bit about that game
yeah sure oh yeah if you remember we can
plug through yeah so anytime work more
color to jail for I was white okay he
has the white pieces are anytime I'm
playing a game of chess I try to figure
out who's the old man who's the young
kid and Jason's in high schools I was
clearly the old man in this situation
which means I want to keep things as
quiet as possible so I just played a g3
and not not Knight of three like usual
yeah yeah I just wanted to avoid tactics
as soon as much as I could all right
just make him prove his positional play
good and so 96 of course is great Bishop
g2 so so there's nothing wrong with c5
but maybe already I felt like he wasn't
sure what his plan was
yeah I I didn't see five invites like
Kings and the instructors where white
gets to do the attacking so I was happy
with that so I just played d3 I mean
obviously I can play pretty much any
move here right and so at this point he
played nice e6 which course again
totally fine but
the whole point of my step is to stay
flexible I played knife three I figured
I'd be happy to play a kid happy to play
symmetrical English okay
whatever so and he played d5 at this
point which really is going into at
Kings Indiana sort of structure okay so
it's pretty much booked at this point
yeah yeah yeah maybe a lot more freedom
before d5 but so so yeah exactly this is
pretty book I'm very happy to play the
white side of a kings in you right so
you get pretty much got to set up your
room yeah yeah he buddy five which I
thought was aggressive particularly
aggressive I mean now it's literally a
king's Indiana temple up since I'm white
so I play d4 and I didn't really
calculate too much I just assumed with
an extra tempo all these tactics that
worked down the tempo would work I like
it you know the tempo Bishop e7 is of
course the normal move when white is
playing this way okay and I played nice
e3 which I don't know seemed very
natural to me of course if he plays d4
92 I I have a tempo up set up again yep
but you'll be okay yeah yeah but he eats
took here which at first I was a little
surprised but looking more and more I
feel like actually so if I take with the
night he doesn't have to take back and
he has a little bit of space vanish for
a while I mean it's like White's totally
fine but I
in keeping with my being the old man I
took with the pawn just to have this
structure where I'm playing for the d5
square and he's playing for a space
advantage I got you by the truth is he
kind of surprised me here because he
took and rook takes and actually my
Knights maybe not so great on c3 because
I'd really like to play pawn to c3 he
has ideas with 94 and night before and I
really really would like to just be able
to play pawn to e3 in this location so I
mean I know this is a line in the tempo
down lines um
so I'm sure it's fine but it was a
little uncomfortable he played Bishop g4
immediately of course ID being some like
if you were his move takes on f3
Bishop takes Knight d4 you know
slams yeah yeah so alright I got to be a
little careful
so again theme of the game is I'm an old
man
maybe rookie ones okay maybe like maybe
five some kind of tactics 95 right but
actually there move I just came back the
tip well played rook f1 which I know is
a normal move again in the temple damn
lines so I figured it'd be fine here and
I won't have to think too much so you're
out of the pin but but now it's the
moment of truth
yeah yeah and so he actually castled
here seems like a very reasonable move I
played Bishop g5 after I played Bishop
g5 I was pretty happy because now I'm
playing against d5 and I'm not too
worried and if he ever takes takes
Knight d4 I can always play Bishop d1
mmm that's that's pretty soon so here he
played rook f d8 and I just went ahead
and took this too took this that way
that way you know you're a fours kid
yeah just like yeah chillin oh yeah I
like yeah and now I play 95 and like I'm
I can always chop this off if he
pressures me and I thought I was a
little better here maybe but nothing to
write home about
yeah so he played I think definitely the
best move here 94 which kind of does
pressure me I mean I can't leave that
night there so I kind of have to take
again if he had taken first I could play
Bishop be 1 and C 3 and right put the
knight back but now I really have to
take because he's here and here so takes
and this is where it got really really
interesting so my instincts in playing
for this position was that I should be a
little better here I have a really nice
night is dark square Bishop isn't really
going anywhere I can always chop it off
but the more I looked at this position I
wasn't really sure what I thought of it
just because it wasn't clear to me how I
make progress like ideally I'd really
like to play like f3 move my rook play
my bishop over Bishop on this diagonal
probably okay but odds they spent about
five minutes here cuz I just I wasn't
really sure how to play it and then I
realized it was a rabbit game so once
you come up yeah I figured I wasn't sure
if I want to play at four but I just
play off three and see if I had to put
it before it figley he he didn't make me
decide on at four because he in this
position came up with rook takes d5
that's a puzzler yeah I was very
surprised by that I mean these bishops
are nice but for an exchange see if
there is some situation where the seed
pod leaves as well and this pawns
running maybe I see an exchange sac
working but this yeah this kind of blew
my mind isn't even gonna get the the
pawn back no yeah he doesn't get you
know so yeah I mean I don't know up till
here I thought maybe I didn't think that
white had anything to write home about
I thought I was just a tiny bit better
it's a little awkward because so if he
plays Bishop h5 I play g4 and then snap
this off now this outside of the game
he's got the double palm yeah so he
didn't want to go with that so I yeah
ask four times visually there should be
six ninety seven doubling the pawns
again Bishop d7 seemed totally
reasonable I thought I was expecting
Bishop d7 so this was a quite a move so
takes and and now you just know you won
the game right I mean I don't know I
mean bishops are are they're good right
like I think there's all these yeah yeah
but there's always all these famous
games where the bishops are worth
exchange like these slicing bishops like
this and then maybe that's some like he
was looking at my my way of looking at
it is I just assume I'm losing until I
have to admit I'm winning okay so one
would just guys you know I could see
this like if you dig the c2 pond off the
board he's got great compensation so but
yeah so I played c3 which I thought was
the most direct way of saying okay
what's your compensation because if you
dig the CND pawns off c3 and for pause
this is a bit more clear right and so I
was really interesting to see if we were
gonna see like pond
three right and then it's like do I have
time for rookie one Bishop f1 I think I
do but that's what I thought kind of the
point of his sacrifice was and he
actually just played he played Bishop d3
and now there's where I really thought
he started maybe to lose the third I
wasn't really sure because my request to
go to you what do you want before you
got it no so and now he went back to g6
okay so now I was like that yeah so I
took he took always gear pieces in the
game right like I wanted to play Bishop
f1 last man and yelling the last guy in
so he played h6 because there's a lot of
back ranks in the position and played
brook c7 at this point I'm like okay
like yeah it's time to put the hammer
yeah yeah I thought this was probably
going to be enough so he played rook e8
I played Bishop f1 with rookie 3 k f2
and he can't really move if he moves the
deep on his rook hangs I like it so and
now he actually went back to d8 and I
just played Bishop d3 and now like the
big thing about bishops right is once
you there's so much better together
right inner parts and now like I can
control Holborn yeah yeah now once
coming off and like he if he takes on d3
and my rook takes back
he's never moving my rook to push this
pawn so I'm winning these ponds on the
side and he resigned here okay that was
nice just don't even he saw the writing
on the wall and done yeah doesn't make
that the higher rate of guy play it out
yeah was always rough being the higher
rated guy let me tell you the price yeah
yeah no I mean I don't know I I guess
going back yeah rook takes d5 really
good puzzle me I think it's I think
maybe white is very slightly more
comfortable after Bishop d7 here
don't think I have anything to write
home about so I would say kind of a
strange sacrifice maybe I'll have to go
maybe baby Jason can redeem himself and
we can get them down here and we're
gonna ask him a powder oh whatever you
think all right well good luck Nick in
the ad in the next couple rounds all
right I'm here once again with eight in
a home who just had a big victory in a
round two of the Friday action quads now
in you were playing a guy in high school
that's much bigger than you in stature
but do you ever let that affect your
play actual strength just by how big oh
well you just have to play I understand
okay well that makes sense so in this
position you had black and you got a lot
more pieces than than the fellow and how
do you finish him off here well play 95
check and then I don't know why he
played King III he probably should have
played lucky enough for something and
survived a bit more yeah but okay so but
he ended up playing the move King to e3
and now you have made in one huh no big
deal yeah well that's cool and well
congrats maybe you'll win the $36 and
gets more Froyo nom nom nom we are back
in studio B for the conclusion of the
Friday action quads I'm here with $36
winner
iris Zhao she defeated Ashish Panda and
the infamous adjourned pari to take a
200 lead in her quad so all she needed
was a draw in the last round but were
you playing for a drug to clinch the
thirty-six bucks no because I wanted to
win because winning is good winning is
good I think in this position well I
know actually that I'm
winning because I'm at the pond now and
his king is somewhat suspicious are you
white or black in this position I'm
black
alright so you wanna flip the board
alright so now everybody sees it from
your perspective alright so so you
played b5 in this position iris but yeah
so you played rook HG one and I just
sort of ignored it because I thought my
attack was faster than his probably
should have calculated more but so I
played b5 and then he went and gg5 and I
have some issues even though I'm up upon
so I should have just gone rook da and
now if he goes g5 and he takes with the
rook then I can take on d1 and then it's
okay because my King can like he's not
going to get chick made it on the H file
okay got it yeah well let's see how the
game actually progressed so I played b5
and then he had g5 and I mean taking is
probably not advisable
yeah I agree because once he takes like
if I make a move he doesn't have to put
his queen in front of his rook you can
just like go here and then I'm checkmate
you yeah so so let's see the reality
like this is pin so I have to go for a
counter play and then he takes here and
then I go g6 because so if I take the
knight if you plays rook takes I I think
I'm just winning but he has pawn takes
in my road so that's doomsday yeah
and so like g6 and then you have this
move Queen h4 which when I played b5
I accidentally didn't see so that was
kind of tough I think probably what I
did is best because everything else
loses like if I go here
here I can't go rook g8 cuz f7 hangs and
then g6 hangs and if I take something
like this I just get mated so I see I
had to do something so I just took the
night and it looks like I'm getting
mated but I think this is a perpetual
because he has to take everything else
gets made it after like before creamy so
he takes no yeah he went King D - I
think maybe his best shot was well I
don't even know let's just see how you
see how I play it out and how you got
the 36 bucks
so this is check check check and were
you satisfied with the result you got
the money
well yeah I wanted to win and I thought
I was winning yep
so so you're almost at mm now chess
expert did you ever dream one day you
would actually become a chess expert
well it hasn't happened yet so I don't
want to jinx it yeah but not actually
not for a while because in the past two
years my improvement has been slow but
I'm aiming from the master of the master
title so the experts expert is nice but
you really want to become a national
master I've beaten some masters already
Oh way I can get there
awesome well good luck to you in the
future congratulations for winning the
36 bucks tonight
[Music]
you
[Music]